[موسيقى]
800 هي غواصه صغيره الحجم يصل طولها الى
واحد وخمسين مترا وارتفاعها يصل الى نحو
عشره امتار كما ستكون لدى هذه الغواصه
القدره على الوصول الى عمق يبلغ 250 مترا
[موسيقى]
اس 800 ستكون لديها القدره ايضا على
البقاء اسفل المياه وبشكل متواصل دون
الصعود الى السطح لمده تصل الى سبعه ايام
كما سيتم تزويدها بمحرك شبه صامت هذا
الامر سيمنحها القدره على التخفي عن اجهزه
الرادار او السونارد
[موسيقى]
المقرر ان يتم تزويد غواصه اس 800 ايضا
بخمسه تربيدات مضاده للسفن والغواصات كما
سيتم تجهيزها بمنظومات ملاحه واتصال
ومراقبه وكذلك انظمه حرب الكترونيه كل هذه
المميزات التي تتمتع بها الغواصه جعل
الكثير من الدول تبدي اهتماما كبيرا بها
من بينها مثلا دول الخليج خاصه انها
تتناسب مع الطبيعه الجغرافيه للمياه التي
تحيط بهذه المنطقه
[موسيقى]